[Music]  ariana grande is back  [Music]  after much anticipation the 24 year old  singer not only dropped her new single  no tears left to cry but also gave us a  music video and it has this vibing out  [Music]  the track marks her first musical  release since the bombing at her concert  in Manchester England in May that left  22 people killed in over 500 injured  while the song doesn't specifically call  out the tragedy it seems Ari is full of  emotions  [Music]  the dangerous woman singer has kept a  low profile in recent months  occasionally sharing pics and videos  from the studio while prepping for her  upcoming album and just this week she  officially returned to Twitter writing  missed you  [Music]  [Applause]